could I ask for reason magazine out why
should libertarians vote for mccain
halen ticket when I was battling against
the president of my own party to stop
the massive prescription drug
entitlement from becoming law it was one
voice in the United States Senate the
morning after we lost that fight on the
House floor who said that what those 25
Republicans tried to do in stopping the
prescription drug bill was right and
that was John became John McCain was the
most vigorous opponents of the first new
entitlement in 40 years and his record
on earmark reform his opposition with
the prescription drug entitlement Paul
in my judgment give evidence to your
deep commitment of limited government
that I think should should reflect and
should resonate very well with
libertarians in America you were an
opponent of mccain feingold and I know
senator Feingold has if anything said
it's his only change in his position is
that it didn't go far enough do you
think that Senator McCain feels the same
way I don't know I haven't talked
recently with John about that issue I'm
a very strong opponent of mccain
feingold i was the house plaintiff in
the lawsuit that challenged it to the
Supreme Court I've been very heartened
that despite the fact that the supreme
court upheld mccain-feingold by a
five-to-four decision several recent
Supreme Court decisions have been
rolling it back
prior restraint on free speech that were
and coming in that Bell are becoming
more evident to the courts and I will
continue to battle to do that you know
the antidote in my judgment for what
ails American political financing can be
dealt with with transparency and
accountability but not more restrictions
we ought to give political parties the
same ability to raise and spend money
that these 527 groups have and that will
be the case we continue to make and I
hope to be able to have that argument
with President McCain thank you very
much